la historia se construye a hombros de
gigantes
en cualquier ámbito cuando aparecen
genios que cambian para siempre las
reglas de una disciplina en el tenis uno
de esos maestros es el suizo Roger
Federer el virtuoso de basilea que
irrumpió en 1998 para redefinir el
significado de lo posible en las líneas
de una pista
en 2003 conquistaría su primer gran slam
en la hierba Sagrada de wimbledon
iniciando una era de absoluto dominio
237 semanas consecutivas como número uno
del mundo
récord absoluto a la fecha
así aparecer sencillo lo difícil
mezclaba la precisión del servicio con
la perfección técnica del dropshot el
poder de la derecha invertida con la
majestuosidad del revés a una mano y
parecía no tener rivales hasta que
apareció el hombre de mallorca el choque
entre la elegancia y la potencia entre
el talento innato y la perseverancia la
rivalidad entre Federer y Nadal fascinó
a generaciones y propulsó al tenis a
niveles de popularidad jamás vistos un
Verdugo que lo dejó en lágrimas en
Australia y lo privó del esquivo título
de Roland garros que solo logró
conquistar una vez en 2009 año en el que
se convirtió en padre y rompió en el all
ingland Club el tope de los 14 slams de
sampras convertido en el nombre récord a
superar Novak Djokovic llegaría para
sumarse a la pelea por el título del más
grande de la historia con el tiempo Rafa
y nole lo superaron en títulos grandes y
las lesiones lo aquejaron en 2016 con un
retorno triunfal en Australia 2017
derrotando a su archirrival en la final
mago dentro de la cancha y filántropo
fuera de ella se convirtió en la
Inspiración de millones fue justamente
de la mano de sus grandes rivales Nadal
Djokovic y Mary que el suizo escogió
Decir adiós rodeado de leyendas en la
libercap la copa que él mismo creó para
rendir homenaje a la historia del
deporte blanco aceptando las
limitaciones de su cuerpo a los 41 años
se bajó del Olimpo del tenis
vuelve a ser humano y Roger prometió no
abandonar el deporte con el que
construyó una historia de amor para la
eternidad